مثل ما يقول البعض بالشلل انقل لنا الصوره
من حيث انت
وسيله انا الان في وسط تل ابيب هنا في
ساحه كابلان الذي عاده ما يتجمع فيها
المتظاهرون الاسرائيليون كل يوم السبت
واليوم الليله هناك مظاهره حاشده تم
الدعوه اليها يتوقع ان تتجاوز الاعداد
150 الف متظاهر في هذه الساحه الان
الاجواء هنا موجود لالاف من المتظاهرين
وعمليات كر وفرع قوات الامن المنتشره
بكثافه في هذه الساحه في وسط تل ابيب هناك
عمليات كروه فرق بين اغلاق شارع رئيسي
وشارع ايلون يغلقه المتظاهرون تاره تفتحوا
قوات الامن تاره اخرى هؤلاء المتظاهرون
وسيله كما تحدث الزميل الياس يشعرون بان
هناك زخما كبيرا قد صب في صالحهم في هذه
اللحظه من الازمه السياسيه في اسرائيل
بوجود قطاعات كبيره في اسرائيل قد اعلنت
اضرابها احتجاجا على مشروع التغيير الذي
يدفع به نتنياهو وشركائه في الائتلاف
تحدثنا عن عمال المطار بمطار بن غوريون
المطار متوقف 73 الف مسافر تمت تم الغاء
رحلاتهم عمال وموظفي شركه الالعاب للطيران
الطيران الاسرائيلي ايضا اعلنوا الاضراب
النقابه العامه في اسرائيل اعلنت اضرابا
المجالس المحليه في جميع انحاء اسرائيل
الاطباء ايضا اعلنوا اضراب حتى تتضح صوره
ما ستؤول اليه الامور السياسيه خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بخطاب نتنياهو المرتقب هل سيقوم
بتعليق هذه الاجراءات كما تتناقلت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ام ان لا يزال لدى
بنتنياهو وفي جعبته اوراق اخرى هؤلاء
المتظاهرون وسيلا الذين تتظاهروا هنا على
مدى اسابيع عده على نحو ثلاثه شهور هم لا
يريدون تاجيل هذه التعديلات الغائها
بالكامل هم يعتبرون التعديلات المشروع
الذي لدى اللي يكون ولدا احزاب اليمين
المتطرفه المتحالفه معه في هذا الائتلاف
هو مشروع تحويل اسرائيل من دوله ديمقراطيه
كما يقولون الى حكم ديكتاتوريه ديني متطرف
وهو بالفعل ما يرفضه هؤلاء هم ليسوا بمعبد
ليسوا يطالبون بتكتيكات سياسيه تاجيل او
او
تعديل او ادخال تعليلات يريدون الغاء هذا
هذه هذا المشروع برمته ويدفعون بهذا
الاتجاه يريدون مشاركه اكبر كانوا ينادون
طيله الاسابيع الماضيه انما كانوا
يتظاهرون كل سبتنا في تل ابيب في المشاركه
ابوسع من اطياف المجتمع الدولي
والديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه حسب قولهم هي
على المحاكم الان يشعرون بان هذا المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
مؤسسات المجتمع المدني الاسرائيليه اباتت
الان في خندقهم وصله
شكرا جزيلا لك